one of the great things about an
infinite adopting an infinite mindset is
I've stopped looking at things in terms
of right wrong good bad but it but but
but taking things more in terms of
context right so I'm not against finite
games if you're in a finite game you
have to play with a finite mindset but
if you're in an infinite game you have
to play with an infinite mindset and
with an infinite game of course there
are finite games of course you have a
product to make that has to get out on
time and there's a beginning middle and
end and you have to meet your deadlines
and we get these products out on time
and meet our finite objectives in order
to advance the infinite vision right so
for example give you a perfect example
so we we're constantly told to know our
strengths and our weaknesses right build
on your strengths mitigate your
weaknesses are they strengths are they
weaknesses or is it all context right so
if you are very self-confident sometimes
you're arrogant
so in other words a strengths can
actually have liability but our
weaknesses sometimes have strengths I'll
give you a perfect example
I am chronically disorganized I mean
it's embarrassing
right and this I've always believed was
a horrible weakness and I beat myself up
for it and I say how I need to fix this
and I try all these systems that don't
really work because you have to be
organized to have an organized system
I'll give you a perfect example of just
how disorganized I am as a young
entrepreneur when I was just starting
out I would go to a networking event and
of course you collect business cards and
a good entrepreneur an organized
entrepreneur would take a business card
from a prospect if somebody goes I think
you're great here's my card and they
would have sent an email on the cab home
and followed up the next day and be like
would love to set up a meeting and come
and show you our product yahoo over here
would lose the business card for the
time I got it to the time I got home
right
two weeks later I'd find it under a pile
of things you know that's with what you
know so brush off the dust bunnies and
I'd call them up and say hey remember we
met at that event two weeks ago they
wanted to work with me even more because
they thought I was busy
[Laughter]
is disorganized a bad thing
the answer is context sometimes yeah it
really is but not always and so now when
I look at myself or I look at the
weaknesses or strengths even of my own
organization I don't I no longer think
in terms of right wrong good bad but I
rather think like this is really
valuable in this context this is this is
really dangerous in this context so I
can mitigate and move things around and
understand what to leverage so it's it's
much more about balance in context than
is about right wrong good bad and all of
this has come from learning to adopt
this infinite mindset that I'm never a
loser or a winner
I'm just ahead and behind sometimes I'm
ahead and sometimes behind but I've
never won and I've never lost
[Music]